[Applause]
tommy what the [ __ ]
you got some nerve standing mia nobody
does that to me who the hell do you
think you are frankie valley or some
kind of big shot please slow down slow
down all right i forgot i thought it was
next week it was friday it was this
friday and you agreed so you're a liar
come on we could talk about this all
right take it easy talk about it
talk to you after what you just did to
me forget it i'm not talking to you wait
a second i thought you were going to
stand me up you look bored you didn't
say anything what do you expect
[Music]
let me make it up to you karen i'll
think about it i remember she's
screaming on the street and i mean loud
but she looked good think about it it's
going to cost you health i'm going to
make it up i'll push you a lot okay
these great eyes just like liz taylor's
at least that's what i thought
hello henry you ready yeah come on
oh no wait a minute what quick gap to
cover that cross my mother sees that of
course
karen
mom
i'd like you to meet my friend henry
hill how do you do hi nice to meet you
my daughter says that uh you're half
jewish um just the good half
thank you sir all right see you later
thanks what are you doing are you
leaving your car watches the car for me
it's easier than leaving it at a garage
and waiting it's a lot quicker that way
huh
i like going this way better than
waiting in line
[Music]
[Music]
how you doing gino
good good
hey good
every time i come here every time you
two
don't you work
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
they will be ready
hey how are you
anthony right in the front great great
thanks anything you need henry just let
me know
hey
i know you're waiting for the table i'll
be right back
[Music]
them twenty dollars each sorry
henry this is with mr tony over there
what over there oh thanks
thank you
what do you do
what what do you do i'm in construction
you don't feel like you're in
construction
i'm a union delegate